Because we need to make the most of our day,...
...here are some ideas to effectively manage your time.
People who worry or procrastinate are wasting time because both involve a lot of thinking.
Rather than spend time thinking about whether or not you should do something,...
...worrying about the best way of doing it, take the "just do it"  approach and be done with it.
Having a routine is another good way of saving time.
Plan your day, because if you know what and how you are going to do something,...
...it saves a lot of time.
An everyday routine is a fabulous timesaving tool.
If you already have one,...
...try to adjust or update it to gain even more free time.
You could add two hours to your day if you get up an hour earlier...
...and go to bed an hour later.
It is absolutely amazing what you can achieve in just an hour when you really focus on a task.